that i i think
that's what i was trying to say uh
and issues of epistemic boundedness are
mixing up and confusing together
biological issues cultural issues
historical issues yes right so but maybe
epistemic boundaries is not a thing so
that was my point uh so it might exist
approximately but uh if you treat it as
that oh my god there's this boundary
there it is there is the wall that
separates us uh from um
from the next country and we will never
be able to cross it because this is uh
for some a natural law the reason in
which human minds have to be constructed
i am not sure if you can actually make
that claim if you can prove that there
is a boundary that we need to run
against well this is hegel's argument
and maybe i can use that to circle back
because hegel's argument is you can
actually only uh
talk about a limit if you have the
capacity to exceed it uh it doesn't make
any sense to say from just this side
that there's a limit
so there are boundaries uh one is
there is loops theorem which says that a
system basically cannot make statements
uh about something outside of itself
also the way in which griddle for
instance talks about the whole of
mathematics and these properties of
mathematics works by building an
automaton that reconstructs the whole of
mathematics that he wants to talk about
from first principles so it talks about
something that is contained in the
system if i want to talk about the whole
of mathematics i have to talk about it
by reconstructing it from first
principles if i cannot make such a
definition i don't know what i'm talking
about right so the world that i am
talking about is one that i need to
construct in the first place and i'm not
able to talk about something that exists
outside of these constructions unless i
can prove that i have constructed things
in the only possible way
which means i have to make statements
about the possible nature of language
itself so this is one of the boundaries
that i can run into
and the other one is uh has to do with
uh and the problem of the access to
of the universe itself and this is much
more um
uh obvious to people than live theory
even though it's related
you cannot exclude the possibility that
for instance that you could be a brain
in the vet some philosophers have tried
to do this but there are slate of hands
and wishful thinking
there is no way that you and me cannot
know beforehand of whether we are
currently in
some kind of weird dream from which we
wake up in the next moment and realize
oh my god this actually didn't happen it
was a fake memory this uh was not true
this is not a description of the
physical universe this was just a weird
illusion that i had in a night dream but
there is no way in which we can in
principle exclude this possibility there
is only ways in which we can
deal with the probabilities based on our
past experiences but if we have never
experienced a certain thing before in
this fundamental way for instance after
i had a long surgery for eight hours i
had extremely lucid dreams that had that
were so intense that i could not in the
intensity distinguish them from daytime
experiences
and it was because of the narcotics that
were still in my bloodstream and i never
had experiences like that before
of course these experiences were just
brain states they had nothing prophetic
about this this was not an alternate
universe that i was dropping in but the
experiential qualities were very similar
and i so my argument is that you can not
possibly make such a distinction
beforehand and that's why you can also
not exclude the possibility of
skepticism and this is one of the
boundaries of what we can be achieving
as a mind we cannot rely on our own
coherence uh in a fundamental sense we
always have to
uh hope and pray that the world
remains as coherent as it appears to me
right now in the next thought